This is it, the crème dele crop of endings,
something I honestly hold on a similar level
to FMAB as it ends just as perfectly as that
series did in my eyes.
We somehow made it out the content cave to
bring you the definitive, last arc of Hells
Paradise, the departure arc.
This part of the series is actually perfect,
like the way everything is wrapped up leaves
me feeling completely content with it.
Yuki Kaku was originally an editor who worked
under the G big Tatsuki Fujimoto during fire
punch and due to his relationship with the
boss of Jump+ he was able to drop this series
without holding back on anything at all, and
its evident throughout this final arc that
man truly didnt.
But before I spoil you on anything that did
happen throughout this final arc...
- after sponsor - But anyway enough of that,
everyone sit back and relax as we dive into
the final part and wrap up everything when
it comes to Hells Paradise, its characters
and the world its situated in.
Start - Don’t you ever just get the need
for a Mech, jump in and wonder…
‘What’s am I?
Which path shall I follow?’
The answer, my fellow Degen's…is the Mech
Arena’s League Divisions!
Before we even get there though, Mecha Arena
is a completely free to play game so there's
literally nothing stopping you.
Once your in, progress through to div 9 by
playing a bunch of easy quick matches, then
when ya smash that out, you’ll get stacked
up with a bunch more stuff to do like 5v5’s
or my personal favorite cause im an absolute
competitive feign; league divisions.
Opinion - Divisions are in my opinion are
the best as the allow you the fastest way
to progress in Mech Arena.
Win Matches, merc nerds, and you’ll earn
Ranking Points.
Earn enough Ranking Points and you’ll go
up a Division.
There are 11 ‘League Divisions’ which
act as an initial track of game progression.
Each time you enter a new Division, there
is a reward which progressively gets better.
Going up a Division is a passive boost to
general progression, as it resets xp caps
on players and points them towards unlocking
more resource crates, along with a extra boost
every win.
it’s completely free to play on Android
and iOS right now, and you can use my personal
link or scan my QR code to get bonuses worth
$30.
We are talking about 1 Skin, 1 Prodigy Crate,
and 5,000 Credits to help kickstart your game.
And if you’re quick, you can add me to friends
as <show profile screenshot> and we can play
some matches together - so don’t wait around!
So kicking things back off and as all of the
flowers around begin disintegrating Mei and
Yuzuriha confront Gui Fa who’s holding onto
that weird looking pot thing.
Gui Fa lets them all know that due to Jikka
cutting down the Divine Banko can senses that
not only is the Banko's Tao destroyed but
also the island's as well, hinting that the
land will soon meet its end.
The reasoning for what Zhu Jin did aswell
was explained to the humans who wouldn't have
had a clue about her want to be praised by
all of her fellow Tensen.
Btw im pretty sure I mentioned this, but when
a Tensen is in a child like state they either
speak like Mei or extremely slowly like Gui
Fa.
Yuzuriha comments on how she felt that Gui
Fa didnt seem bothered at all by the fact
the Tensen's are all dying, but is told by
him that death is not the end for them.
Every being passes from life, but their Toa
will still remain.
Even though reversing the process is insanely
hard, pretty much impossible under normal
circumstances.
The little man reveals that that they have
a chance of being revived through the Basin,
pot urn looking thing he’s holding.
Inside of the basin it holds all of the fallen
Tensen’s ovules which after 1,000 years
had passed will allow them to fully revive.
Yuzuriha who doesn't care about what happens
1000 years from now decides that it was time
for her and Mei to enter the floodgates but
is warned by Gui Fa that yes she might now
care about the future, but she better fret
about what's going to happen in the coming
hours, as Rien Cannot be stopped.
Meanwhile at the floodgates, Shugen bursts
his way through the overgrowth and grabs onto
the anchors line in an attempt to halt the
ships departure to Japan.
Idk what man was thinking and as we probably
all saw coming the line snaps allowing Rien
their safe departure.
However turns out Shugen actually tore the
rope in half himself to use the anchor as
a grappling hook to fling himself all the
way up into the boat.
Standing infront of the final boss, Shugen
states that he doesn't care what cargo he
intends to move, but he will never reach the
mainland!
Looking back at him Rien tells him the same,
in that not a single soul will leave this
island alive.
Darting at the immortal, she manages to easily
defend herself against Shugen but also tries
to hold back as to not damage the ship's interior.
Shugen screams at himself not to falter and
slashes Rien across the chest, connecting
with the tanden, but this has no effect due
to his Water Tao not being the right match
to hinder his Wood Tao.
Pointing his finger forth he then shoots a
blast of Tao which connects directly with
the spot on Shugen's chest where his heart
would be.
Sliding back while gritting his teeth, the
Yamada states that they will not fall to the
dark arts of these feigns, revealing that
somehow Rien's blast of Tao actually hit Tenza’s
headband which he’d placed under his robe.
Thinking about how Tenza saved him once more,
Shugen notes that reckless assault will only
serve him poorly.
Instead... to win he must call forth the true
essence of what it means to be a Yamada Asaemon.
Choosing to replicate the abilities of the
other Yamada to fight, Shugen bursts forth
and uses a plethora of his close friends abilities
to slash at the creature.
Rien senses something strange with Shugen's
Tao and upon receiving another cut to his
tanden from a replicated attack used by Shion,
starts to cough up blood.
Jumping back in fear, Rien is just confused
as he was sure this dudes Tao wasn't meant
to affect him.
Yet, after looking closer, realizes that Shugen
has the ability to change the attribute of
his Tao, which they always assumed was impossible.
Seeing that they have to take him seriously,
Rien drops the control they had over the flames
around them to give her full attention during
the battle.
Shugen who aint concerned with these flames
tries to attack, yet Rien who would have loved
to study this man on any other day, takes
things up a notch and severs Shugen's right
arm with a feathered fan.
She then states that the time for tinkering
is over and changes to their true form as
Yin allows for a far greater focus.
Back with the children sized Tensen, Mei asks
Gui Fa as to what exactly Rien's true goal
was.
Flashing into a dark room and using their
Tao illusion ability, Gui Fa shows Mei and
Yuzuriha what they saw earlier in Rien's laboratory.
Like remember in the last arc where he got
surprised at a revelation that wasn't expanded
on, well here its shown that not only did
he find the ovules, but also an extensive
amount of research on restoring the body of
someone, not the soul.
Then beyond that he noticed a wall that wasn't
in place, behind that unfamiliar door hidden
by an illusion was even more research and
notes that eluded to the true goal of Rien.
We all think its to merc everyone in Japan
and yes that is true, but just as everyone
reacts to these clones looking after a mysterious
crippled figure in a bed, mei lets them all
know that that person is the grand master
.
A sudden noise then breaks them out of the
illusion.
Gui Fa explains that the noise came from Rien
who’d managed to finally set sail on the
open ocean after having dealt with Shugen.
Despite the circumstance, Mei asks Gui Fa
to continue with there explanation on Jofuku's
plans.
Gui Fa tells Mei that they are making an incorrect
assumption, Jofuku had indeed died long ago
that their master had already died and had
been turned into a gold statue in order for
his body to be preserved after undergoing
Arborification.
Back in the past when they were first not
permitted to meet with the master, it wasn't
because he was busy, more that he had actually
arborified and passed from the mortal realm.
For the last 700 years Rien has worked non
stop for this day.
The way of Tao explains that the soul and
body are one and through this it led her to
believe they would have been able to revive
the soul just like any other part of a body.
Gui Fa then tells Mei and Yuzuriha that Rien's
true goal is to revive Jofuku using the Tao
of all citizens inside of Japan, not use it
to make a perfect elixir for themselves like
we originally thought.
Knowing that Jofuku was already dead and while
speaking in their native Chinese tounge, Me
asks Gui Fa who was the Hōko that they found
earlier on when getting the basin.
The little man reveals that the person was
the real body of Rien, who’d begun arborifying
in that room.
The person they’re familiar with is merely
a puppet crafted out of Tao.
The puppets insane quality is due to a level
of Tao manipulation that surpasses what every
other Tensen is capable of.
All of it points to one solid conclusion in
his eyes, Rien is not a Tensen, but infact
a human and the wife of Jofuku.
When Jofuku left ancient China with his 3000
voyagers, one of them was indeed Rien.
The Tensen all originally thought they were
an amalgamation of mystic Tao and Flower Tao,
yet this was false.
First Rien created another version of herself
and from that the other Tensen were all born.
Back when a change first started to show in
Rien, it wasn't because she was mad, but because
her body had started to under go arborification
limiting her time and only allowing her to
control the clone version of herself remotely.
Gui Fa who doesn't fully understand the matters
beyond his comprehension just calls Rien foolish
and starts to criticize the notion of love
humans have.
In his eyes it makes them pretty and cruel,
full of arrogance lacking in style, suspicious
and paranoid and even still it drives them
to sacrifice absolutely everything they already
have.
After over 1000 years of building everything,
Rien is willing to throw away everything if
it just means they get a chance at holding
their love once more.
Then with a final statement he tells them
that within two hours Rien will reach Japan
to initiate their plan.
Taking this all in, Yuzuriha panics wanting
some form of break after everything they’ve
been through.
She even questions if this is just another
trap the Tensen are trying to set up for them,
but Gui Fa explains that he’s stuck in a
paradox of his own.
He wants Rien to leave, but also wants to
save her.
Unable to understand the feelings he currently
he has, he asks Mei for her opinion on the
matter.
Before she could give her answer, Yuzuriha
hits her over the head and tells her that
they should hurry to where the others are.
As a parting gift, Gui Fa warns her that according
to the I Ching they found in Rien's room.
Which for those who forgot, I Ching allows
the Tensen to tell the fortune of specific
people.
Through this he was able to determine that
most likely, only two men and one woman will
survive, shocking Yuzuriha.
Gui Fa relies on the on this Ching to foresee
fate and those who’s names are unknown cannot
be include, but Rien themselves may be among
those counted.
One thing is for sure though, the art of I
Ching does not lie.
Having left Gui Fa, Yuzuriha and Mei then
arrive at the entrance to the floodgates with
everyone gathered (with the exception of Gantetsusai
who went ahead to try to stop Rien from departing,
as well as the absence of the Aza brothers
who have yet to return.)
Obviously this is because well he’s holding
onto the ovule of his big bro.
After discussing how they need to find a specific
ship with a light load to catch the main vessel,
the group enters the floodgates, only to be
left disappointed that all the ships have
been burned.
Looking out through the wreckages, Nurugai
spots one unharmed ship but is told by Shion
that they will not be able to use it since
the wreckage of all of the other vessels is
blocking the water from flowing and allowing
them to move out.
With everyone left hopeless, Gabimaru see’s
another vision of his wife and dives into
the water to try to remove the debris.
Jikka tries reasoning with him, but our boy
screams back that re-thinking is impossible,
he only has one goal and refuses to give up.
Wanting to help and seeing the pain in his
eyes, both Sagiri and Nurugai dive in to help,
despite it being an impossible task.
Standing behind them, our little girl Mei
thinks back to what Gui Fa asked her.
Pointing her hands forth and closing her eyes,
Yuzuriha then sees Mei about to unleash her
power, which she objects to doing since she
knows that her body will be at risk.
She pleads with her, asking if she wanted
to Talk with Rien and Jofuku, but with a smile
on her face Mei explodes and transforms into
her Kishikai, commanding everyone to get on
the ship while she handles the task of making
a path.
Ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh WHY MEI
Back in the early days and while looking after
the first Humans who came to the island with
them, Mei asks Jofuku why he decided to bring
people to the island since the emperor only
seeks the elixir.
Jofuku explains to her that because Tao goes
far beyond just typical human understanding
and for that reason she shouldn't concern
herself with these difficult matters.
In another memory and after Rien finished
a session of dank Bōchū Jutsu with Jofuku,
Mei is told by her to not feel ashamed by
the practice as even the young ones will perform
this training some day, so she mustn't continue
to harbor doubts.
Then as the children grew older, she recalls
her punishment for defying Rien and how she
felt powerless to do anything about it.
She was fed up with it all, so she fled and
told herself that she was unable to make a
change, but After recalling Gui Fa's past
question as to why she returned to Hōrai,
Mei remembers that it was once again because
she was fed up with it all....
In the present, Mei explodes into her Kishikai
state and continues that she was fed up with
have fled over and over.
Not anymore though, now she flaps all five
of her massive wings and blows away the wreckage,
giving everyone a clear enough path to get
onboard the ship.
Sagiri prepares herself to yell out to Mei
in concern, but is interrupted by Gabimaru,
who begins yelling out himself, telling her
that she is running the risk of dying if she
continues to stay in her Kishikai form and
her original goal of being able to have the
normal life will fade away.
Mei then returns to normal, dropping out of
her fighting form and hugs both Sagiri and
Gabimaru individually.
She thanks both of them for everything they
have done for her, but this is how she takes
responsibility for everything.
She tells the confused Gabi and Sagiri that
watching them has a way of filling her with
courage and finally thanks Sagiri for combing
her hair, before slapping her palms together
revealing that they were actually in an illusion
and Mei had transported everyone to the ship.
As Mei uses one last gust of her wings, she
pushes the ship forth allowing them to rush
after the final boss.
In her last moments as she begins withering
away, Mei apologizes to everyone for not being
to sail off with them, to her father, to her
family, and to Rien for not realizing their
feelings after they banished her and how she
could not stop them.
Elsewhere and aboard the ship, our G, the
legend, king of the samurai, Tamiya Gantetsusai
walks his way through the flames of hell.
Over the other side of the burning ship, Rien
reclaims the Elixir of Life after finding
it lying next to the defeated Shugen.
She then wonders as to why he had it on him
but quickly dismisses the question after having
it back in her hands.
With the elixir returned, Rien sees that all
that is left to do is put her faith in the
Paradise Butterflies and becomes happy to
know that her dream will soon come true.
As things were going well in her favor, the
puppet randomly starts to feel its body suffering
due to the real Rien's Tao control starting
to lessen.
With time running short, Rien hopes that she
reaches Japan soon.
Meanwhile on the flaming deck, Gantetsusai
finds Shugen unconscious and starts to wonder
as to why his severed arm is not bleeding.
Shugen then wakes up badly injured and sees
Gantetsusai standing right in front of him
without Fuchi by his side, but soon remembers
as to why this was not the case.
Gantetsusai tells Shugen that he was glad
that he managed to wake up, since it wouldnt
have felt right to cut him while he was still
down.
Somehow Shugen manages to block the attack
on time but falls down after having been knocked
off balance losing his sword in the process.
Gantetsusai tells Shugen that its useless
for him to fight back now that he has lost
his right arm but is told by the injured Asaemon
that as a samurai he can not give up.
Just straight up annoyed Gantetsusai kicks
Shugen in the face and screams that all of
them are a band of fools, all this damn honor
and dignity forced him to cut down his own
friend.
He punches him in the face and kicks his stomach
while telling him that his ways of living
are utterly corrupt.
Shugen makes an attempt to defend himself
by swinging his sword but falls down after
losing his balance once again.
Gantetsusai turns his back on Shugen, calls
him out to be a purely pathetic samurai and
tells him that he doesn't care if he decides
to burn to death.
As he watches the blade of his sword burn
within the fire, Shugen grabs it and cauterizes
the stump of his right arm after remembering
Fuchi's advice about disinfecting a wound.
He practices getting used to swinging his
sword with his left arm in front of Gantetsusai
and recalls the time Fuchi discussed with
him how the human body is a tool and that
by searching its construction and limits one
can manipulate it as they see fit.
Gantetsusai then becomes shocked to see that
Shugen in a matter of moments managed to adapted
to using his left arm to wield his sword.
The Yamada screams to Gantetsusai that Fuchi
was caught up in his sentimentality but says
that his samurai spirit lives within him.
Falling into another memory of the past he
recalls the time where Shugen pointed out
how weird the Yamada clan was.
Fuchi tho said that even though they got rocks
thrown at them, the clan allowed him to partake
in his offbeat proclivities and for that reason
its always going to be extremely dear to him.
Shugen then proceeds to tell Gantetsusai that
someone like him can never understand a samurai's
sense of duty to protect all those they hold
dear and that he has long since abandoned
sentimentality.
After he finishes his statement, Shugen's
eyes mysteriously invert.
Not noticing this, big G points out the fact
that he sheds tears quite a lot for someone
without sentimentality and prepares to fight
him but senses something different.
Earlier before arriving at the floodgates,
Shugen senses a strange energy emitting from
the gourd containing the Elixir of Life and
becomes suspicious of its contents, prompting
him to straight up open the bottle and taste
test it for any underlying poisons.
Much to the shock of the shinobi accompany
him he spits out its remains and then declares
it to be safe for consumption.
By the time he faces Gantetsusai though its
obvious that the full effects of the elixir
is shown to have run its course as Shugen's
eyes start to change, along with his heart
beating fast.
In a moment he then darts at the elderly G
and tries to strike him down.
Comparing him to last time, Gantetsusai notices
that Shugen is able to fight properly again
as if nothing went wrong and that the way
he moves his body is similar to Fuchi's.
To him its as if he’s fighting against his
friend, which complicated things for him and
meant that he didnt defend as the fake Fuchi
sliced at his chest.
After his robe is cut, Gantetsusai sees the
bandages Fuchi used to heal him with before
his death and decides to stop fighting, keeling
down instead.
Looking at him, Shugen question if he was
ready to surrender.
Yeah in a freaking million years though, like
I think you need to understand that BIG Gantetsusai
is built differently, he tells Shugen that
he was just remembering the reason as to why
he boarded the ship in the first place and
how he never even intended to fight him.
Slowly standing up, Gantetsusai explains that
in the past he toured the provinces fighting
anyone of strength, but at some point they
never ever scratched the itch he sought to
find.
His nick name "Blade Dragon", came about after
he took down his very first monster, a Ryukotsu
known to us feeble English readers as a ship's
"keel".
With that said, Gantetsusai smiles as he brings
his sword down and slashes the ship in two
causing a massing explosion as the energy
blast connects with the ocean below.
Falling back with his wounds reopened he laughs
that he was unable to completely cut the ship
in half but figures that another attempt would
be able to.
Absolutely enraged with what's happened, Rien
floating there in the sky asks what in the
world he’s just done.
Gantetsusai that he could not stop the ship
since it is made out of Tao.
As she begins to slowly stroll towards the
duo now, Gantetsusai says that he hasn't managed
to cleave the ship in two, but he did managed
to slow her down enough for our next crew.
Guessing that his work is done, he readies
himself to get off the ship instead of continuing
to fight, stating that his life was a gift
given to him and that he will not throw it
away.
However, he does tell both Rien and Shugen
that someone else stronger than him will arrive
shortly and that he hopes their ready to face
him.
Looking over the boat and through the flames
he becomes happy to see that Gabimaru and
the squad had finally pulled up.
Gabimaru jumps onboard the ship, compliments
Gantetsusai for the work he has done, and
tells him that he will handle the task of
taking down the ship as he faces both Rien
and Shugen.
ITS THE FINAL SHOWDOWN!!!
Before boarding the ships themselves, Gabimaru
pointed out that the flames were far too strong
for everyone but him to jump onboard.
Alone and walking through the flames like
a Yamabushi Monk, Gabimaru approaches Rien
and Shugen.
Shugen standing there himself, takes note
of the setting in front of him and compares
it to the past portrait he and Eizen looked
at depicting hell.
Which just goes back to how the series is
called Jigokuraku and how that word when broken
down means 1 heaven and 2 hells.
Wonder if that also refers to the amount of
survivors on this mission 2 men and 1 woman,
could have been infront of our eyes from the
get go.
Either way lets push forth and discover how
Yuki ended this amazing series.
Nevertheless Shugen then announces that he
will for the sake of the world and the clan
punish even the devil himself.
Hearing his war cry, Gabimaru commented that
he’s already used to this hellish domain,
while Rien on the other hand just found her
situation with them to be irritating.
In an instant all of them clash blades, hands
and feet in a three way free for all.
Continuing all of them then weave through
each others strikes.
Rien blocks Gabimaru's attack and tells him
that she will not allow him to damage the
ship any further and will use everything they
have to kill him while stomping their foot
on the ninja.
Rien sees Shugen about to attack her from
behind and uses her fan to counter.
Taking things up a level, Shugen manages to
anticipates her attack using the Tao sensory
ability and comes in to strike using Shion's
Wood affinity.
However, Rien who’s just in another class
when it comes to the level of skill, stands
on the tip of Shugen's sword, telling him
as a Shinsen, the highest class of hermit,
a human such as himself will not be able to
harm her, before raising her hand and firing
a point blank invisible Tao attack.
Watching from the side, Gabimaru sees that
Rien is a lot stronger than Zhu Jin and Ran
but remembers from his conversation with Jikka
earlier that as long as Rien's priority is
keeping the ship intact he should be able
to hold his own.
In the battle though Rien becomes shocked
to see her tanden slightly cut and sees that
it was done by no one other than our queen,
Sagiri, who boarded the ship after remembering
that Gabimaru will need her help since her
Wood Tao will actually harm Rien.
After Nurugai makes a point that their best
chances at survival is fighting together,
the survivors (with the exception of Jikka
cause mans on the sneak) all decide to board
Rien's ship to take her down together.
Rien states that a gathering of humans will
do nothing to stop her, however Gabi silences
her nonsense, he already knows that they’re
just a bunch of randoms who came together.
BUT they will do anything to survive and make
it home.
Meanwhile on the survivors' ship, Jikka lays
down, while in support of his comrades, and
says that he will do his job of guarding the
ship.
Knowing that Rien's Tao is too powerful, Yuzuriha
and Gabimaru decide that the best course of
action is to try to have her deplete her Tao,
similar to how they managed to defeat Ran,
with everyone else acting as distractions.
Sprinting forth Yuzuriha makes the first attack
by using her Ninpo: concealed armor ability
in combination with Ninpo: puppet slime to
create her supreme move: Crimson confection
guard.
She knows that only two dudes and 1 chick
will survive, but pushes forth either way
and puts her faith in Sagiri and Shion, knowing
that the both of them can make the final cut
together.
Rien destroys Yuzuriha's armored soldiers
but is struck in the head after failing to
notice the sneaky Kunoichi charging towards
her.
Even still, Rien manages to simply send her
back with a Tao infused blast, however in
that moment she's caught of guard by Nurugai
who while sliding behind them, remembers Shion's
teachings in the use of Tao and cuts Rien's
left arm using Tenza's Itto-Ryu ultimate pounding
torrent technique.
With their body falling to bits, Rien quickly
reconnects it and uses the partially severed
branch arm to grab ahold of Nurugai but luckily
for our mountain warrior has her limb cut
off by the Blade Dragon..
Gabi who comes down from above notices a perfect
opportunity and in combination with Gantetsusai’s
merciless eye killer move: Skypeak Splitter
uses his secret art: Shandi gust to simultaneously
light on fire and cut the immortals tanden.
With Rien left wide open, Gabimaru calls out
to Sagiri and Shion to perform their combined
attack to destroy Rien's tanden.
Stepping forth in perfect motion, both the
Yamada use their ultimate technique: Hidden
Blade dual wheel moon to bisect the immortals
top half sending it flying up into the air
and bringing the intense battle to an end.
Jokes as if its over yet, we still got a goooood
amount to go.
In retaliation the Tensen simply claps their
hands together, revealing that she's perfectly
fine and the events that had transpired were
an illusion of Tao created by her.
Looking to her left she watches Shion falls
down infront of her.
With Sagiri stunned still, Rien walks forth
revealing that everyone (except for Shugen,
Isuzu, Kiyomaru, and Gabimaru) has fallen.
Irritated with the pathetic foolishness of
these Humans, she explains to Sagiri that
Hermits are those who touch apon the truths
of this divine plane.
The only thing that has ever remained beyond
their reach is the world of the gods themselves,
still in her eyes she will soon even reach
that state, revealing the buddha like Kishikai
state that she wields.
All that remains is the complete destruction
of Waguo.
After seeing Rien enter her Kishikai form,
Gabimaru prepares to use a technique against
her, yet, Rien instantly blasts him in the
face with a Tao lightning bolt before he is
given a chance to attack.
I just realized, its kinda like a mix of Buddha
and Raijin, but yeah.
Sagiri comes and actually manages to stab
Rien's tanden from behind but is told by the
Tensen that her Tao is far too weak to harm
her body.
Seeing that Sagiri was about to be crushed,
Shugen jumps in to save Sagiri from Rien's
Tao manipulation and orders both Isuzu and
Kiyomaru to have the criminals return to the
ship, explaining that they cannot allow a
monster to steal the Yamada clan's duty to
execute them.
WHICH IS CRAZY.
Hearing that some of that were gonna escape
allowing them to escape, Rien dismantles the
entirety of the ships exterior, while keeping
the room where Jofuku is placed intact.
As she holds on to Kiyomaru's hand, Sagiri
becomes shocked to see that the young Asaemon
has been crushed by a piece of the debris
that was previously sent flying.
Poor duuude, RIP Kiyo.
Seeing her comrade, Isuzu becomes shocked
and rushes towards their direction.
However, Rien senses her and literally takes
control of Isuzu's body, before ultimately
crushing her in front of Shugen, much to his
horror.
Screaming for both of his friends, Shugen
jumps upto where the immortal is and tries
to attack Rien in a blind fit of rage.
Sneaking up from behind as this happened,
Gabimaru grabs onto Rien and sets her ablaze
with an intense amounts of flames, which in
turn allows the meglomaniac Shugen a chance
to cut off one of Rien's arms but also as
a side effect is caught.
While trying to incinerate her, Gabimaru has
a sudden memory of Yui's face and ends up
ceases his attack, realizing that he’ll
perish if he continues.
Looking at is own hand, he then notices that
his Tao is starting to resonate with Rien's
and because of that he falls into a similar
dark world to that of Zhu Jin's before suddenly
bursting into a bundle of flowers and falling
to the ground arborified.
So back before they boarded the ship, Jikka
did his thing and made a bunch of predictions
as to how the survivors should go about fighting,
but believes that there is no solution.
Knowing that, Jikka decides to stay on the
ship as ya know they've gotta have someone
guarding it, much to Yuzuriha's annoyance.
In the present, Jikka watches the outcome
on the ship and sees that he was right on
the survivors not being able to stop Rien.
He then brings out a drinking barrel and decides
to toast to the end of humanity.
On board the skeleton of a vessel and while
watching Gabimaru arborify, Rien says that
she knows not of his ambitions, but hopes
that he has pleasant dreams and as the go
to land the finishing blow believe that all
those who are still alive will die in the
fire or will lose the will to fight as they
soon reach Japan.
Sitting there herself, Sagiri feels that she's
utterly powerless and reflects on all of the
times she has failed to do anything against
her enemies.
She then looks at Gabimaru and begins to say
she gives up, but stops in her tracks after
seeing just how bad his arborfication is.
Rising to his feet, Shugen, badly burned from
Gabimaru's flames, orders Sagiri to return
to the other ship since she cannot fight in
the state she is in.
He looks at the reflection in his blade and
to him its obvious that our girl lost her
resolve after witnessing too many of her friends
pass away.
So and since she is literally the only heir
left for the clan (apart from Jikka) he orders
her to board the other vessel as he cant afford
to lose her.
Having survived being fatally wounded, Shugen
boldly states that he will make Isuzu and
Kiyomaru proud by eternally carrying out his
clan's duty without any doubt within him.
As she senses Shugen's Tao surging, Sagiri
remembers the time Shugen congratulated her
for earning a ranking and how she will bring
about a change as a woman to the clan's male
dominant trade.
Speaking up Sagiri questions Shugen if its
even possible for people to live without doubt,
and if they do does it even translate to strength?
Over the time on this mission, she’s come
face to face with doubt over and over again.
Her doubt as well as those of the criminals,
executioners and even Tensen.
Everyone struggles and doubts themselves only
to struggle some more.
If abandoning doubt is truly the way of the
samurai, then like Shion, she rebukes the
roles and states that she isn't one in that
case.
With all of the fallen Yamada placing a hand
on her back she screams that she refuses to
leave these feelings behind and instead while
picking up her sword exclaims that TO THE
BITTER END, SHE WILL REMAIN FULL OF DOUBT
AND CONFUSION AS FOR THAT IS WHO SHE IS.
N im like hell yeah this actually gave me
the biggest spur of encouragement.
Im way to harsh on myself for my pronunciation
or the way I speak, or how bad I am at reading,
but stuff it.
Like Sagiri here im thanking Shugen for these
words as we are truly grateful to him.
Looking at her, Shugen feels this random sensation
emitting from Sagiri, its neither tranquility
or intensity but something else completely.
Sagiri herself then looks back at Gabimaru
and asks him in her mind if it was okay for
her to have faith...
In a time once passed we see Gabimaru being
introduced to the 8th daughter of the chief
Yui.
Initially she becomes spooked after Gabimaru
raises his hand towards her and pats her head
as if she's some kinda pet.
Yui questions his action, to which Gabimaru
answers that ever since that day he’d wanted
to become more open with.
But at the time it just didnt feel real, he’d
stolen lives so he thought he never qualified
for a normal life.
Yui says that she doesn’t understand where
he was coming from and tells Gabimaru that
he is still eligible to have a normal life
despite his past sins.
She notes that he seemed to be suffering some
kind of pain, but the acts of regret and reflection
are all apart of ones atonement.
She asked if it was enough that just a single
person accepted him for who he was causing
Gabi to question what she meant.
Thinking on this, Gabi believes that it is
enough and that he should accept himself for
who he is so that he can finally be free of
his burden and move on.
In the present, Sagiri raises her sword above
Gabimaru's Arborified body and tells him that
he must accept his burdens while continuing
to live on.
She then brings her sword down and executes
the roles she was initially charged with.
Momentarily, Gabimaru regains consciousness,
with his body back to normal, and finds his
own flower arborified head in front of him.
Noticing that his sense of self finally returned,
Sagiri explains that she had to amputate the
parts of his body that were deeply rooted
with vines and used the most outlandish method
of Tao Restoration by pressing his Tanden
next to hers.
While he stands there impressed with her approach,
Sagiri states that she cannot see a way to
defeat their enemy but is told by Gabimaru
that they need to keep fighting as long as
their alive, much to her satisfaction.
Gabimaru also thanks Sagiri for leading him
back towards doubt to increase the speed of
his healing.
(she did this by like guiding the thoughts
in his head, bring up his wife etc).
After Sagiri jokes about actually following
through with her original task, Gabimaru says
that they cannot rely on fate due to the risk
of failure and also readies himself to fight
alongside Sagiri.
Shion and Nurugai fall into the ocean while
carrying Gantetsusai who remains unconscious.
Jikka then tries to bring them onboard the
ship as requested by Shion but falls into
the ocean as well due to being intoxicated.
After everyone (including Yuzuriha) is brought
back on the ship, Jikka lets them know that
it would not matter if they had saved him
since he believes that Rien is utterly unstoppable.
While on the other ship, Rien senses Tao growing
from where Gabimaru and Sagiri's are, and
looks in their direction.
Jumping towards her Rien fends off a plethora
of attacks and uses a bolt of Tao lightning
as an attack but misses Sagiri after Gabimaru
pulls her out of the way.
Nurugai and Shion watch as Gabimaru and Sagiri
fight together in perfect synchronization
but also points out that they need some sort
of strategy.
Darting forth, Gabi is handed Sagiri's sword
and goes in to strike Rien's tanden.
However, Jikka notes that that strategy will
not work since the hindering attribute will
lose the necessary power needed.
Using another strategy, Gabimaru attempts
to use Sagiri as a human sword by holding
her by the legs, but quickly dismisses the
idea.
In light of their ridiculous tactics, Rien
sees that she cant afford to waste any more
time fighting them and must take down Sagiri
using her bulked up arms.
On the other side of the boat, Shugen looks
at Sagiri and remembers the time he felt worried
that she was selected for the shogun's mission.
He assumed that her kindness would be a hinderance,
but now in light of things starts to see that
it doesn't.
Sagiri remembers how Gabimaru pointed out
to her how she lost to Shija due to giving
into anger instead of focusing on the middle
path that gives Tao its power and in that
moment accepts that both strength, weakness,
and doubt make her who she is.
After her Tao is strengthen, Sagiri attacks
Rien with a clear mindset of knowing that
she is the "spear" and the “linchpin”
that will take her down while our sneaky sneaker,
Gabimaru is the spy from within the shadows,
as after all being a sneaky shinobi is what
he does best.
Moments before Sagiri made her charge and
remembering that Rien's true goal is to revive
Jofuku, Gabimaru tells her to remember what
happens when those extreme emotions take over.
It weakens their Tao.
Tao is held together by a clean discord between
both Yin and Yang, to much to either side
and the power fades.
So if her heart is filled with rage, then
maybe they have a chance.
In reality and as Sagiri is placating the
big boss, Gabimaru lands in the same room
as the gilded statue of Jo Fuku, causing the
buddha wannabe to fall directly into their
trap.
As he charges towards Jofuku's corpse, with
his Ninpō: Ascetic Blaze activated, Gabimaru
knows that when her Tao is disrupted, Sagiri
will slash her tanden.
The timing has to be perfect, but as he goes
to smash down on the floor of the boat notices
that there is a post-wedding brazier, a flower
crown, and a pair of traditional wedding garbs
laid out infront of the statue.
Stunned Gabi thinks back to when Yuzuriha
said Rein’s true goal was to revive her
master, yet after seeing what's infront of
him, Gabimaru for the first time realizes
that Rien and Jofuku are a married couple.
Beginning to falter, he tries pushing himself
forth as he knows he needs to be in perfect
sync with Sagiri and this truly is there last
moment, missing it means death.
Seeing his wife with the smile on her face
and knowing the pain that it’d cause someone
to loose their beloved, he drops to the floor
unable to follow through.
Unexpectedly, the merchant of death, sir order
66 Shugen jumps out from behind Gabimaru,
and screams that to be a samurai means being
prepared to give your life at any moment.
For DUTY is the pride of a samurai and the
pride of the Yamada Clan.
Raising up his sword he envisions Eizen doing
the same.
Free of thought till death, with singular
devotion, towards the embrace of deaths warm
grasp, he brings down his blade with the vision
of a demonic Eizen behind him, allowing him
to deal a powerful Tao-imbued sword slash
that not only slices Jofuku's gilded statue
in 2, but the entire ship itself.
Having witnessed confirmed passing of her
loved one, Rien screams in horror as her late
husband's body is destroyed, gives Sagiri
the perfect opportunity to bisect the Tensen
and destroy her plant ovule.
So with everything lining up for our girl,
she swings her own blade forth and manages
to slice the immortal Kishikai in two.
With the battle finally over, Sagiri, Gabimaru,
and Shugen are seen exhausted while the upper
half of the puppet starts to disintegrate
inside of the ocean.
Having defeating the final immortal, the ship
starts to fall apart, since the only thing
that was keeping it held together was Rien's
Tao.
After retrieving the Elixir of Life, Gabimaru
yells out to Sagiri to grab his hand while
they make their way back to the ship.
Sagiri wants to look for Shugen, but once
she turns around and sees that he has passed
away due to overexerting too much of his Tao
in his previous attack continues forth.
Randomly Gabimaru Sagiri suddenly receives
a gapping wound as if she was hit by some
sort of Tao attack directly in the stomach.
With Gabimaru left in shock he turns to sees
that the culprit is Rien, who stands before
them with her body being partially covered
in flowers.
Her only desire was to be with her husband
and now because of that she states that this
is the end of everything.
She furiously vows to Gabimaru that she will
take away everything from him and the other
humans.
Suddenly Gabimaru's left hand is then crushed
by Rien causing him to drop to the ground.
Laying there and after remembering a past
lesson from Eizen about how a Kaishaku is
needed when performing seppuku, since the
punishment does not have the victim die immediately,
Sagiri comes up with the idea of using hemostasis
on herself, but quickly concludes that it
may not work to help her recover.
She then remembers Gui Fa's past words to
her on how the only thing each side can do
now is steal lives from each other and ponders
if that is truly the only recourse.
After seeing Gabimaru punctured by Rien, Nurugai
prepares to rush over to assist him.
However, Jikka grabs her and explains her
that power will not be able to stop Rien.
Back over with the dying immortal and while
having Gabimaru suffer for his ‘crimes’,
Rien remembers how he hesitated to destroy
Jofuku's body and asks him as to why he did
so.
Gabimaru answers that in the moment he was
about to strike, an image of his wife appeared
in his mind, which caused him to end up faltering.
As Rien thinks about her lost love, Gabimaru
tries to reason with her, saying that maybe
he thought they could relate.
Having heard these words, Rien looks back
on her loving memories with Jofuku, how he
slowly started to grow old and arborify while
she till the very end stayed by his side.
Remembering the love that she once felt and
beginning to cry herself, She brings her hands
together and in a final act decides to heal
Gabimaru and Sagiri's wounds
With everyone watching, even the survivors
on the nearby boat, Rien starts to disintergrate,
turning her body into a bunch of flower petals.
In the afterlife its said that Rien who was
finally at piece managed to have her soul
reunite with her husband.
Jikka, while still intoxicated, becomes happy
with the outcome of the battle and tells Gabimaru
and Sagiri that he had faith in them all along,
much to their, as well as Shion's, Nurugai's,
and Gantetsusai's, annoyance.
On the other hand, Yuzuriha suggests in forgiving
him since he is the one in charge of steering
the ship.
Jikka becomes delighted to know that Yuzuriha
was on his side and tells them that he was
going to get back to "rowing" the ship, which
Nurugai and Yuzuriha commented on being ineffective.
As they make their way towards Edo, which
is around an hour or so away, Shion informs
everyone that he and Nurugai will not be returning
and will go their separate ways on a small
boat.
He also reminds them about their situation
with who will get the pardon upon returning.
After seeing Sagiri depressed, Yuzuriha tells
her that a happy ending was never going to
be possible for them and asks if an executioner
like her started to become fond of criminals.
Sagiri wipes a tear as she happily answers
yes, after coming to see them as people dear
to her and asks if it was wrong of her to
not know the answer to the situation.
Yuzuriha says no and points out that everyone
else besides herself was a villain, which
leads to everyone having a comical conversation
about just how villainous each person is.
After he and his wife are pointed out to be
evil, Gabimaru shocks everyone after he laughs
at the ridiculous thought of Yui being a villain.
Having become interested in knowing more about
his wife, the groups asks Gabimaru to tell
them more about her, to which he agrees.
Later, Gabimaru, Yuzuriha, Gantetsusai, and
Sagiri stand up to try and figure out who
will return with the Elixir of Life.
Shortly after, the shogun becomes informed
that a ship has returned from the island voyage
with only two men and one woman boarding.
At the magistrate, Sagiri and Jikka present
themselves to the shogun as the two only surviving
Asaemons to make it out alive and are ordered
by Aoki to make their report.
Sagiri remembers earlier back how Jikka will
take the initiative in making the report but
wonders as to what he will do.
Jikka first bows his head in gratitude for
being assigned to the mission and tells them
that, since Shugen has lost his life during
the mission, he will be the one to make the
report (covering for our boy, love to see
it).
Jikka then presents the deliverance of the
Elixir of Life and reports that the only surviving
criminal was Tamiya Gantetsusai after the
other criminals, Gabimaru, Aza Chōbei, Yuzuriha,
and Nurugai, were executed by him.
With this, Gantetsusai is then pardoned by
the shogun (and I never doubted BIG G FOR
A SECOND I knew man was gonna make it home,
like the blade dragon, aint no one killing
our man).
Before allowing Aoki to end all matters, Jikka
asks him about the arrangements that were
made concerning the Iwagakure chief.
Aoki confirms to Jikka that the Iwagakure
chief was dealt with, after the latter testified
that the leader had his own ambitions during
the mission, which was viewed as treason against
the shogun, and presents the leader's severed
head, much to Sagiri's shock.
Aoki also reports that the body of the chief
has been transformed into a tree after they
forced him to test the effects of the elixir
before beheading him, as per Jikka's suggestion.
Aoki then questions if the state of the chief
could be viewed as immortality but is convinced
by Jikka that the shogun could live forever
as a divine tree to watch over his family
in exchange for his humanity.
After their business with the shogun was over,
Jikka falls down tired and becomes pleased
that things somehow went according to plan.
Earlier on the ship, Jikka saw that Gabimaru
and Yuzuriha had picked Gantetsusai as the
one to receive the pardon due to his high
reputation and suggests that they themselves
abandon their names and former life upon separating
on boats.
Which just like Yuzuriha points out, it connects
this with the I Ching Gui Fa warned her about
on Kotaku.
As they prepare to depart, Sagiri receives
a goodbye hug from Nurugai and yells out her
farewells to Yuzuriha who happily waves back
already having started to leave on her own
vessel.
Looking over, she then sees that Gabimaru
is the last to depart.
The two meet each others gazes and as Gabi
walks by happily say their goodbyes without
even having to say a word.
In the present, Jikka sees Sagiri thinking
about the others and tries to cheer her up,
stating that it was fate that brought everyone
together and now all they can do is hope that
whatever path in life they are on, it will
make them happy.
After hearing these words, Sagiri looks up
with a smile as she starts to cry.
Meanwhile, Tōma is revealed to have somehow
found a boat and departed from Kotaku, but
not by himself, dude is mysteriously accompanied
by an unknown person.
After the arrangements were made by Jikka,
Gabimaru who had finally managed to make it
home becomes shocked to see Yui standing atop
some stairs and eagerly runs towards her.
After finally being reunited, the couple set
out on their own path in life.
(so we finally made it huh, our boy is home
with his wife who exists and he didnt have
to merc big G in the process, pure bliss)
Skipping forth in time though, over in British
Hong Kong during the mid-1800s, a young man
sitting in a chair notices that the men he
took down do not look like the locals, to
which he’s informed by his brother that
these men are from England due to the recent
war causing chaos in power.
You know who it is, the BANDIT BROTHERS TOMA
AND CHOBEI BIG CHILLING TOGETHER, Chōbei
hearing this becomes pleased, since he believes
that it is an opportunity for him to take
over the city and declares to the Englishmen
that he now rules the underworld from here
on out..
So as some of you might've guessed the reason
Chōbei is alive, is somewhat similar to Gabi,
but with the added use of the Tensen's special
pot.
His brother stimulated his ovule while keeping
him stored in the urn to help speed up his
regeneration.
One of them men suddenly whips out a gun and
calls Chōbei a freaking baby, which Tōma
translates for him and after learning that
he was insulted, Chōbei transforms into his
breakdown state and merks the dude for insulting
him.
At the same time, in a teahouse in Japan's
Hitoyoshi Domain, Shion gives his opinion
on Nurugai's new appearance, saying she was
too young to wear that, but is told that she
prefers her new look since the other girls
around her dress the same.
Nurugai is then hit on by two men, which she
found flattering, but sees Shion ward them
off with a threat.
Nurugai becomes disappointed but is given
a lecture by Shion about how all men are either
beasts or thieves, then noticing something
on her face begins to clean the dirt off.
The two then decide to head North to find
Nurugai's people and having watched this entire
thing happen a random woman wonders if they
are father and daughter despite not seeing
any resemblances.
Meanwhile, while traveling, Sagiri talks to
Yuzuriha about how Gantetsusai has opened
up a dōjō dedicated towards medicine and
swordsmanship.
In a flash over there and after finishing
up a patient, Gantetsusai is issued a challenge
by a man at the door but yells at him to silence
himself.
Sagiri then reveals that Jikka has taken over
the Yamada clan as the next head and is now
enjoying an easy life just like he wanted.
After being asked by Yuzuriha as to why she
has chosen to travel, Sagiri answers that
it was a good way to help her polish her blade
testing skills but also says that she wanted
to leave home for a while.
Yuzuriha figures that her current journey
is to visit Gabimaru but remembers her past
statement on it being a bad idea to do so.
Sagiri replies that she could not help the
urge for a little reunion.
She then asks her mate why she decided to
accompany her, to which Yuzuriha answers its
because she's her body guard who secretly
loves her.
Looking over at a random woman though, Yuzuriha
then spots Yui outside her house and as soon
as Sagiri see’s her, screams out her name
in surprise.
Standing outside together the three girls
all introduce each other and begin to have
a chat about all of the things that have happened
with them.
Once they all walk inside, Yui offers to wake
Gabimaru up to have him see them which causes
the chicks to be surprised as Gabi probably
didnt sleep at all on the island (apart from
ya know the knockouts).
Sagiri also finds it hard to believe this
but states that he was no longer the same
"Gabimaru" as before.
All of them then roll over to check up on
Gabimaru and after seeing just how out to
it he is, states that they probably cant rouse
him as dudes gone from stray cat to house
cat.
Letting him be then, we skip away from Gabi
for the final time and leave the three woman
to have a fat yarn with each other about everything
that has happened.
Time then fast-forwards several centuries
where Gui Fa is seen ending an online class
while living in human society (funnily this
ended during ovid so the whole online class
thing hits different when you think that for
the last 2 years of this series man was stuck
in doors writing).
Mei then enters the room to tell Gui Fa that
Ju Fa and Tao Fa have sprouted which was a
lot earlier than anticipated.
Walking off together Gui Fa just
says that he hopes
they others progress just as well.